alors bonjour à vous je parlerai pas
d'évasion fiscale c'est absolument pas
mon domaine
par contre je vais vous parler du monde
merveilleux des paiements au qu'est ce
que je vais faire je vais vous parler
mon quotidien
ce qui se passe ce qui est ma vie ok et
je vais vous donner les trois gros
changement qui arrivent pour bouleverser
mentaux que mon petit quotidien et vous
allez voir c'est assez classique donc je
vois vous êtes vous êtes genou cette
dynamique vous avez plein de projets en
tête dans les années qui vont venir
moi j'ai déjà perdu quelques cheveux
dans les dernières batailles et je vais
essayer de vous donner deux trois
repères sur mon expérience et les
petites leçons à apprendre dans dans vos
dans vos projets futurs
ok bon mon quotidien
j'ai une grande chance avec le domaine
des paiements pas ce que vous en faites
tous vous vous en faites via des cartes
il ya du cash les smartphones maintenant
très très très populaire les laptops
ok donc vous faites des paiements tout
le temps tout le temps tout le temps
chez bnp on en traite à peu près 4
milliard par an
les 4 milliard par an et on a des jours
où c'est un peu la panique on en retrait
de 25 millions en charge par jour ok
donc période de noël et des choses comme
ça ça c'est ce n'est de nombreux
traitements et ça c'est une vraie
première leçon de la vie c'est que ma
réalité ce n'est pas de regarder les 25
milliards qui partent c'est de regarder
celles qui ne marchent pas ok
et vous allez voir ça dans votre
quotidien je vais parler beaucoup de
changements et de trucs qui vont arriver
dans le futur plein de choses très
excitantes et honnêtement c'est plus
facile de parler du futur que parler du
aujourd'hui mais quand vous travaillez
et que vous devez vendre à des clients
en fait il vous pose la question où il
est aujourd'hui
est-ce que ça va marcher ok et donc quoi
que vous faites
gérer le quotidien parce que si vous
gérez pas le quotidien vous n'allez
jamais réussir à vendre le futur sa
première leçon de la vie que j'ai
découvert ok alors il ya trois choses
qui changent de mon petit quotidien
hockey et c'est des choses qui sont
assez classiques
on a trois choses dans les payements on
a on a quelque chose qui s'appelle les
paiements instantanés
je vais expliquer on a tout ce qui est
si les banquiers qu'on l'a vite lien
l'inventer donc c'est très rigoureux
c'est celle le psd 2 la dsp 2 c'est tout
ce qui est à voir avec l'ouverture du du
marché vers les fintec des choses comme
ça je vais revenir aussi et puis je vais
toucher à big data et à l'analytique ok
donc ça c'est les 3 changements qui
arrive je vais passer sur le premier
vous le savez peut-être pas mais si vous
êtes au restaurant le vendredi et que
vous voulez payer un collègue pour
l'excellent repas que vous avez eue
manquer si vous vous êtes notre collègue
dans une autre banque que vous en faites
vous le payez mais là personne ne reçoit
pas l'argent avant lundi après midi
lundi soir si ça va bien moqué et temps
en temps s'il a le malheur d'être à
l'étranger ça se peut que ça arrive
mardi mercredi hockey et honnêtement
dans le monde dans lequel on vit ça
c'est quand même pas terrible quoi on
est sur amazon on à l'autre colis qui
arrive en 24 heures mais alors un
payement on n'est pas foutu de le faire
passer en 24 heures
ça ça ne va pas manquer et donc on est
en train de super vite à miner les
payements donc les banquiers ont faim
nous on fait des choses bien on passe de
trois quatre cinq jours et on va les
passer directement à 10
il seconde 10 secondes sur la zone
européenne
ok ça c'est ce qui va commencer à
apparaître à partir de l'année prochaine
ok tout ça c'est dû à de la technologie
nouvelle à la bloquer ne fait il ya
plein de bonnes choses là dedans c'est
ça qui va arriver sur la zone européenne
on va pouvoir commencer à faire des
paiements ou votre collègue votre ami à
l'argent il peut le dépenser endéans des
10 secondes
ok donc la problématique c'est pas une
problématique non technologiques dans le
monde dans lequel je vis en fait le
problème que j'ai c'est un problème de
personnes et d'organisations c'est que
les banquiers
il aime bien travailler de 9 à sac et il
n'aime pas travailler après et il aime
surtout pas travailler le soir la nuit
ou le week end ou les jours fériés et là
on est en train de mettre en place une
organisation qui va devoir traiter les
paiements 24 être sur la zone européenne
avec toutes les langues différentes à
traiter tous les incidents à traiter des
choses comme ça et c'est ça qui cause le
problème est donc deuxième leçon de la
vie la technologie c'est fantastique
mais généralement c'est les hommes les
femmes qu'il faut changer pour que ça
marche hockey et ça c'est la réalité
une machine face et a programmé mais
alors les hommes et les femmes
il faut vraiment les convaincre pour
pour y aller ok il ça ça demande un
petit peu d'audace et beaucoup de
travail fort ok première chose ok
paiement de cette année vitesse
d'exécution la deuxième chose ça ça va
sans doute vous intéresser si vous
commencez dès fintec et des choses comme
ça en fait il ya eu une très très bonne
idée de la commission européenne c'est
d'ouvrir l'infrastructure de la banque
au fintec ok c'est un petit peu comme
les enfin le chemin de fer l'électricité
les choses comme ça c'est qu'on sait par
le réseau des trains et du service qui
circulent dessus
ok et donc l'idée c'est de pouvoir
offrir d'être une banque et d'offrir des
services de paiement des souplesses des
services d'ouverture de compte
des services de crédit des choses comme
ça donc ils veulent essayer d'ouvrir la
concurrence pour éviter que bnp paribas
ou société générale soient les seuls à
pouvoir faire quelque chose au pied
danser une ouverture du marché est bon
je vous parle depuis l'es2 puis cinq
minutes là sur les paiements mais en
fait je sais je sais que le paiement ça
vous intéresse pas ok je sais que ça
vous intéresse pas en fait qui vous
intéresse dans le payement
c'est le service que vous recevez avant
ou après il ya des paiements qui vous
nous sommes heureux c'est quand vous
recevez votre salaire ou que votre
parent vous paye votre allocation du
moins et il ya des paiements qui vous
rendent un petit peu moins heureux c'est
qu'on doit payer ses factures ou qu'on
doit payer cette taxe
ok c'est ça le but le payement en tant
que tel on s'en fout c'est le but qu'il
faut et donc une deuxième leçon de la
vie c'est quand vous faites des choses
ne regardez pas la transaction en tant
que tel regarder ce que le client final
veut faire avec
ok les fintec qui sont dans le monde en
ce moment en train de faire les
paiements les paypal de ce monde qui ont
commencé il ya longtemps à des choses
comme ça ils n'ont pas regardé le cra
cra de comment la réseaux fonctionnent
ils se sont dits corse quel est le
besoin quel est le problème
aujourd'hui du client et comment le
résout hockey et c'est pour ça qu'ils
ont vraiment vraiment réussi à embêter
bnp paribas socgen et tous les autres
banques qui parce que les banquiers sont
trop à regarder leur nombril et pas
assez à regarder le monde extérieur
deuxième grande leçon regardé dehors et
pas l'intérieur
troisième chose je vais arriver au big
data donc 4 milliards de transactions
on est sur la zone européenne
donc on a tous les pays contre est ok il
ya des pays en france où on a à peu près
15 20% du marché interne 15% 20% de tous
les paiements qui passe en belgique on a
35 % du marché on a 35 % du marché qui
passe on a énormément de données dans
les paiements aussi combien
qui paie quoi ou etc etc et pendant ce
temps on en a rien fait rien ça restait
dans les paiements
on en a jamais jamais employé ça ait de
nouveau la technologie va commencer à
nous permettre de regarder ce qu'il ya
dans les payements hockey très très très
intéressant mais en fait on veut le
faire un petit peu différemment on veut
pas juste faire du marketing on veut
éviter ce qui m'embête un peu c'est je
vais pour surbooking je réserve un hôtel
et pendant six mois je reçois les mêmes
offres pour la ville où j'étais il ya
six mois et en fait je retourne plus là
je ne comprends pas pourquoi ses jambes
rappelle qu' ils ont un hôtel à montréal
alors que j'étais à montréal et si moi
j'y retourne plus pendant des années des
années des années ce qu'on va essayer de
faire c'est du prédictifs
ok ce que ce que ce qu'on a découvert et
ça c'est vraiment une beauté c'est que
en fait les avions airbus
quand ils veulent en fait les moteurs
envoie des sondes vers la big data
hockey et en fait quand l'avion atterrit
ils peuvent à l'avant ce prix de voir
les pièces qui vont casser et les
remplacer avant que les pièces tombent
en panne ça c'est merveilleux pour nous
ce qu'on veut faire c'est les paiements
on veut identifier de façon prédictif
les problèmes avant que les incidents
arrivent ça ça va nous résoudre plein de
problèmes et donc ce qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on va mettre beaucoup
d'intelligence et on va pas regarder le
passé d'essayer de résoudre les
problèmes du passé on va essayer de les
prévoir de l'est predict et de les
prévoir à l avance et d'essayer de
réparer l'incident avant que le client
le voit ok beaucoup de big data beaucoup
d'intelligence beaucoup de technologie
pour y arriver mais ça va nous vraiment
nous faire avancer en terme de
réparation et en termes de qualité de
service pour le client
pas pour leur vendre des choses mais
juste pour être bien meilleure par
rapport à ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
ok donc les trois choses qui vont m'a
pas quittée dans ma petite vie
alors les trois leçons de la vie où j'ai
perdu mes cheveux
[Musique]
moi j'ai j'ai commencé comme consultant
j'ai fait là j'ai travaillé beaucoup
beaucoup en europe j'ai fait l'allemagne
le long trajet fait plein de pays
différents et en fait j'ai trouvé ça
toujours très intéressant de regarder
vraiment du traditionnel de regarder des
industries qui sont très très très
anciennes qui sont là depuis 100 ans qui
font la même chose depuis 100 ans et
d'essayer d'appliquer des nouvelles
technologies de nouvelles façons de
faire est vraiment de les secouer
ok il ya vraiment des choses incroyables
à faire vraiment il ya si vous
réussissez à faire ça fait ça c'est
vraiment très très intéressant quand
vous avez plein de projets regardez le
monde comme il l'est aujourd'hui
regardez ce qui marche pas et secoué il
ya plein d'opportunités pour le faire au
qu'est la technologie aujourd'hui est
incroyable incroyable quand j'ai
commencé il ya 10 20 ans à travailler
c'était c'était vraiment il fallait qu
des tout il fallait vraiment expliquer à
la machine comment ça allait fonctionner
c'était c'était dur c'était très très
dur maintenant on met de la data dans
une machine et la machine apprend avec
la date assez incroyable la technologie
qui existe des choses qu'ils prenaient
des années pour traiter aujourd'hui en
quelques millisecondes
on a la réponse est très très très
impressionnant et donc d'appliquer ces
technologies à un ancien monte on
révolutionne ce monde c'est très très
très impressionnant très très
impressionnant
la dernière chose j'ai par les buttes et
techno projet des choses comme ça mais
il n'y a qu'une chose dont vous allez
vous souvenir c'est les gens avec qui
vous avez travaillé
ok c'est les équipes les gens qui aident
le festival à être montés cetc les gens
que vous allez vous rappelez
quoi que vous faites quoi que vous
fassiez enterré vous bien entouré de
gens en qui vous avez confiance qu'ils
sont prêts à aller avec vous jusqu'au
bout ok c'est ces gens là dont vous
allez vous rappeler la technologie va
évoluer la machine va lui elle et les
dates avons changé les hommes et les
femmes avec qui vous avez travaillé
c'est ça qui va vraiment vous portez et
rendre votre projet fantastiquement
intéressant merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]